nein wir ihr schmeißt eine grillparty
doch zehn minuten bevor die gäste kommen
fällt durch als er vergessen
die getränkepreise stellen wer hilft
euch jetzt wichtig diese weg heute geht
es um express kühlen ich habe hier vier
flaschen sprudel und zehn minuten zeit
wie stark bekomme ich den strudel in
zehn minuten abgebaut
[Musik]
eine flasche nummer 1 single vielfach
ist haben wir noch ein bisschen zeit um
zu klären was wärme und kälte eigentlich
genau ist hier in dieser küche hat
dieselbe temperatur wie nichts
raumtemperatur war auch nötig ist aber
sehr völkisch wehrmacht als zum beispiel
dieser mit zahlen müsse
was ich hier fühle ist meine eigene
körperwärme das ist der tisch wärmer
sind halt nichts anderes als dass holz
ein schlechter wärmeleiter ist als
metall eine körperwärme wie viel
schneller folge der geleitet als bei
hall die wärme weitergeleitet und was
ist denn eigentlich genau temperatur ist
eigentlich ist anderes als die
geschwindigkeit der bewegung von
molekülen
je langsamer und weniger sich moleküle
bewegen desto kälter ist und je
schneller und mehr das molekül bewegen
bist du wer reist beispiel wasser
wahrheit bei raumtemperatur glücklich
die wassermoleküle sind beweglich heißt
aber noch zusammen bin ich ist hitze
verdampfte dass die wassermoleküle
fliegen wild durch den raum sie bewegen
sich mehr und wenn ich was wieder
erstarrt
als die wassermoleküle den sich nur noch
sehr wenig und werden weitergeleitet
werden moleküle ihre bewegungsenergie
aufeinander übertragbar angegeben ist
hier ein schnelles uhlig fühlt und ein
langsames molekül das langsame computer
hersteller wolke kommt alles anders
anzutragen deal also moleküle abbremsen
können wir die abkühlende mir langsam
moleküle mit schnellem kühl in kontakt
bringen also etwas kaltes mit etwas
warmem kontakt bringen
jährlich legen und kühle abgetrennt und
so kühl stéphane ab und die beta die
umgebung die berme leitet der schneller
ist die abkühlung
schauen wir mal wie kalt wird ist die
flasche habe ihm die vier war natürlich
nur oder hauptsächlich kontakt mit der
luft und duft ist ein sehr schlechter
wärmeleiter luft hat eine sehr geringe
dichte das heißt es gibt einfach sehr
wir nicht wo die bühne auf welche die
wärme übertragen werden kann und wir
haben wir immerhin 21 9 grad bildet also
normaler raumtemperatur hat also nicht
allzu viel gebracht
diese klasse zehn minuten in alt hier
natürlich entwickeln mehr kontakt mit
dem welt aber das natürlich immer noch
sehr viel luft dazwischen jetzt auch um
1,6 gelten also auch nicht besonders
effektiv
[Musik]
wenn aber eine mischung aus wasser und
als nebel kann ich eine bessere kühlung
l4 das machen ersten blick ein wenig und
intuitiv
wenn man den einzigen käse als wasser
dort hatte eine tiefe von wärmeleitung
als luft außer dem traktor und wasser
als gemisch auch ziemlich schnell eine
temperatur von etwa null grad und wird
nach zehn minuten schöne 9,1 grad
celsius alles hat für schritt besser
jetzt allerdings wenn ihr ein bisschen
salz oder zucker oder so etwas darf ich
in japan löst hinzugeben hier ist der
effekt der so genannten gefriert von
erniedrigung auch dasselbe nutzern auch
im winter wenn manche straßen mit sei
gestreut sobald irgendetwas in wasser
hören eher niedrig dass durch die vier
punkte was heißt es gefriert sich
hierbei nur platz sondern bei minus grad
ein wassereis salz gemisch steht also
der gefrierpunkt des wassers ende trägt
das eis zu schmelzen und diese schmelzen
benötigt energie und diese energie wird
in form von wärme dem gemisch entzogen
und das ganze wird ein deutlich kälter
als null grad wunderbare 4,8 liter
wasser als wald mischung könnt ihr eure
getränke bürger deutlich schneller
unterkühlt als in zehn minuten ich würde
vorschlagen waren eine kleine community
konnte ihr probiert zwar aber auch und
schreibt in die kommentare
wie schnell ihr hinbekommen hat red wing
von raumtemperatur auf
kühlschranktemperatur oder zu kochen
und wenn ihr schon mal kommen ihren weiß
könnt ihr wie immer eure fragen mit in
die kommentare schreiben
vielleicht hätte ich gern mal in einem
video beantworten bis dahin sicher